und dann sagst mir bitte ins Gesicht
dass auf der Welt dann besseren Ort geht
um den Jungs ein Abschied zu feiern ist
tinder hey du deine Augen dann gut zu
meiner Bettwäsche passen
lesbisch
100%ig
Lutz mir müssen da jetzt aber wirklich
nicht mit irgendwelche Weiber aufreißen
du heiratsmann
Marathonlauf
[Musik]
aber ich liebe die Sabine doch ja ich
liebe dich auch aber heute nicht nur so
das war einmal Sex und sie mountain
da haben wir dann ein Radler
und die Kässpatzen nehme ich an sonst
sieht die verfressene Spaßbremse
ja ja ich bin die verfressende
Spaßbremse mit dem Geldbeutel der sich
jetzt nicht mehr ganz so weit öffnen
dass die Damen einfach nicht die Säcke
stehen
die Plätze noch frei
selbstverständlich sind die beiden
Plätze noch frei wenn sich die Damen
bitte niederlegen wollen
so schöne Kurven und ich habe kein brems
dabei was heute ist halt noch hier
führen
ja
die Ladies ein kleiner Tipp von mir wenn
sie sich die Herrschaften schön trinken
wollen empfehle ich was Hochprozentiges
dann bitte zweimal pisten-zombies XXL
die hochkant doch schon da
kommt sofort gell
sagen sie könnten Sie mir bitte den
Rücken massieren ich habe mir da was im
Lift gezerrt ein Rücken massieren ich
ihren
Nina
ich mag jetzt nicht arrogant wirken aber
ich weiß ich könnte sie sehr sehr
glücklich machen wieso gehst du schon
ich bin Fotograf und ich suche genauso
ein Gesicht wie deins und ich bin Heidi
Klum und habe heute leider kein Foto für
dich
Manfred Sabine was machst du am Häuser
der
Begrüßung für die letzte Frau in deinem
Leben wir heiraten nämlich am kommenden
Dienstag bis dahin kriegen sie in Wien
versprochen mein Manfred Städte der
braucht eine Frau mit Erfahrung eine
Frau mit einer straffen Hand
gameribälle
das ist mir aber doch einmal
interessieren bitte was machst du da
jetzt
bisschen
du bist auch teuer was werde ich hier
machen in den Bergen und Tauchkurs ich
tu ein bisschen frische Luft schnappen
was sonst und zufällig Schnaps die
frische Luft genau da wo der zukünftiger
Mann und ich seine Jungs sein Abschied
feiern wollen oder
vielleicht um euch die Festplatten zu
löschen der trifft man sie 150 km
ganz zufällig auf 1000 Meter genau auf
derer Skihütten oder apropos zufällig
das Schlamper mit der ich dich letzte
Woche im Café gesehen habe die schaut
ganz anders aus als deine Annette los
anders das war die Cousine von meiner
Annette ja
in der Familie so lieb haben
wirklich nur im ganz kleinen Kreis also
nur so unter uns Männer
bloß so
viel Spaß noch
immer mehr auf der sportlichen Seite
auch von der Figur her ich glaube ich
habe dich auch schon mein Marathon
laufen sehen heute ist mein Bierzelt
oder drei Stunden braucht das zum Klo
bist wieder unterscheiden
viel Spaß noch die Herrschaften die
Party wäre wohl gelaufen gehen wir wie
wir
sie meine Freundin und ich
geht doch nicht ich bin doch mit meinem
Freund und den konnte ich doch da jetzt
einfach so sitzen lassen doch können sie
nein im Ernst und wenn ich ihn
verspreche dass das eine Nacht wird die
Sie nie vergessen werden
wirklich jederzeit gar keine Frage
brauchen wir nicht drüber reden aber ich
bin verlobt und da möchte ich heute
nicht dass du
jetzt müssen wir schauen dass wir einen
sehr sehr guten Arzt für dich finden
mit irgendwelche Männer da und du warst
schon was mit die Sabine im
Verlobungsring hat wenn es dort dabei
George Clooney miteinander steht dann
wegschmeißen tanzen die Sabine darf
niemals im Verlobungsring wegschmeißen
natürlich das also ich sag dir tue es
nicht
heiraten
auf die Frauen
ich muss jetzt am frische Luft du bist
an der frischen Luft du Depp
so das war jetzt hier zweimal Zombie XXL
wo sind sie jetzt hiegler für die Hosen
hat es nicht so gefunden mit dem
rentnerschaum wenn ihr jetzt irgendwas
überhaupt nicht Brauner sein ist ja
natürlich blöden spricht
ich muss jetzt einfach ein paar Minuten
nachdenken
ist treu wie Gold gegen den ist der
Papst der poliger Mist gottschalter
und 50 extra weil sie alte Ziege uns
vorher die ganze Zeit beleidigt haben
ich habe mir Gedanken gemacht
aber wie mir zwei heiraten
sondern so eine Art offene Beziehung
führen
ist jetzt einfach mal ist eher nichts
du Fräuleins ich habe so gerade in
meinem Leben ein paar Weichen gestellt
und von dem her würde ich fragen ob wir
meine Antwort auf deine Frage wollen ob
ich die noch einmal
du bist ein Mann in den besten Jahren
mit allen Möglichkeiten und da herum
meine bleibst sicher nicht lange nur so
und mir ginge jetzt ein bisschen
gummibärchensprühen echt wie geht das
[Applaus]
meine Augenfarbe passt sehr gut zur
Bettwäsche
lauter Lesben drumherum